so why would you want to take apple cider vinegar
before bed well there's many reasons i'm going to
talk about the blood sugar reason acetic acid
which is the main acid in apple cider vinegar
is very anti-glycemic what does that mean it
means it reduces your blood sugars after a meal
acetic acid also helps you reduce
blood sugars in the morning
there's something that occurs called the dawn
phenomena or dawn effect where you wake up and
your blood sugars are higher now normally when you
wake up your blood sugars should be low because
you didn't eat all night long and especially if
you're on keto and you're not eating carbohydrates
why in the world would your blood sugars be high
well that's because that high blood sugar is not
coming from your diet it's coming from your
liver your liver is making extra glucose from
protein and fat and ketones okay that's
called gluconeogenesis the formation of
new sugar from non-carbohydrate sources and the
reason why it's doing that is because you have
insulin resistance you have a problem with your
blood sugars you can be pre-diabetic or a diabetic
if you're not a pre-diabetic or diabetic you just
have insulin resistance that's all that means
all right so now why does acetic acid also vinegar
lower your blood sugars well number one it blocks
the enzymes to break down starches so if you're
not breaking down the starches the starches can
go through you and not get absorbed number two
acetic acid reduces the liver's production of
gluconeogenesis the formation of new sugar and
this is very important if you're a diabetic
you should be taking apple cider vinegar before
bed you will wake up with your blood sugars better
and that means the need for medication comes down
and number three the reason why acetic acid helps
your blood sugars is because acetic acid makes
insulin more sensitive which is going to improve
insulin resistance and it's going to increase
the need for more insulin and help your pancreas
to produce less insulin so it's going to
help hyperglycemia as well as hypoglycemia
so if you have hyperglycemia or low blood sugar
definitely start taking apple cider vinegar before
bed and even after meals i would recommend
two tablespoons in a glass of water if you
haven't seen my other videos on apple cider
vinegar i put the link down below check it out
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story
please share it in the link down below